in the basement of a provincial Greek
hospital doctor Pablos Pavley dis has a
grim overwhelming almost a futile task
this is inside a shoebox plastic bags of
personal belongings watches rings
bracelets glasses there's a label on
each to the date the body was found and
a number because none of the victims who
once wore these items has a name not yet
this is the key this is the heart of
your of your investigations
exactly exactly with just these the
doctor's mission is to reunite the dead
with their families the river where they
died is not far from the hospital this
is the far north east of Greece and the
Evros marks the border with Turkey it's
the European Union's external border and
supposedly it's the easiest way to reach
Europe a boat or in places a swim offers
the chance of asylum they think this was
2018 second discovery in early January
naked and with only jewelry for clues
everything about the victim is noted
down and filed we found dates about the
first week the doctor has been doing
this for 17 years another image shows
the most recent victim to be found his
face is horrific ly decomposed what's
happened to his eyes he was found in a
hut having made it across the river he's
wearing four pairs of trousers he
thought they'd keep him warm
he died of hypothermia so you can see
the numbers the river stretches over a
hundred miles along the border the whole
thing is a militarized zone
it's off limits for us but in places
it's possible to reach the banks it is
the hunters and fishermen who find the
bodies first bend it it's not one it's
not - it's not three it's not five
there are many dead bodies drifting down
the river the river outside here at
least doesn't look that dangerous that
other bank is Turkey we don't know how
many make it across and slip into Europe
undetected the EU Border Agency
intercepted 5500 people crossing the
river last year
that's an 80% increase on 2016 from the
moment that we find a dead body if I am
fishing for example and I see a body I
tug it to the bank then I call the
authorities and they come and deal with
it diera it's about five months in the
morgue another body for this
with a more laughing statistically he is
likely to be Syrian or intriguingly
Turkish they now represent the second
highest nationality making the journey
fleeing the hardline government of
President Erdogan for three months we
take it about the end for the in the
cemetery the cemetery is more of a mass
grave in a field in the hills next to a
Muslim village the local Imam has a plan
of the field and a record of the
identification numbers in the doctors
files each mound has a number there
really is very little dignity here but
that's what makes doctor Pavley does his
job so important he wants to give each
of those who lie here their dignity back
their identity back and to return them
to their family each of these bags
represents a family who doesn't yet know
relatives left wandering small clues
which are collated by the Red Cross they
form a jigsaw of sorts but there is no
global database just the kindness of a
few mark stone Sky News in Greece